la primera vez que jeffs tool tienes vio
a la reina isabel tiene 8 años la salud
en la calle mientras ondeaba la bandera
británica el día de la coronación de la
monarca el segundo encuentro fue más
cercano poso para él mientras le hacía
el retrato que hoy descubre el oro el
college de la universidad de oxford
pensé que no era permitido darle la mano
a la reina
y extendió su mano y dije perdón señora
pero he estado limpiando la paleta para
estar aquí probablemente me manche las
manos con pintura y ella dijo oh no
importa esta mañana estaba usando mi
pluma y la pluma explotó probablemente
manche las mías con tinta esta era su
manera de decir que está bien online
en seis sesiones privadas y largas
conversaciones
isabel dejó ver sus conocimientos de
arte y su perspicacia
y afuera del palacio los guardias
marchan arriba y abajo la banda está
tocando ella me miró por la ventana y
dijo esa es una nota equivocada
ayer le tomó 40 horas perfeccionar el
estilo y color de pelo de la reina y
seis meses terminaré el cuadro pero en
segundos descubrió la verdadera y sabe
si ella ha conocido a todos los primeros
ministros a todos los presidentes a
nivel internacional desde los años
cincuenta me siento que es una opinión
similar tiene chris jackson quien ha
sido el fotógrafo de la reina por 20
años después de acompañar las recorridos
por el mundo o fotografiar la en el día
a día jackson sabe que escocia es uno de
sus lugares favoritos y obviamente tiene
un gran sentido del humor y le encanta
cuando está con su familia y si
realmente la esperilla especialmente con
sus nietos crisis la ha fotografiado
exclusivamente en cuatro oportunidades
pero él ha tomado millones de fotos de
ella es esta persona a la que la gente
admira que ha estado ahí durante toda
nuestra vida en el entorno con 96 años y
saber seguirá siendo un icono y
fotografiada en cada aparición pública
no solo por profesionales sino por
millones de personas